people liked what they heard out of
janet yellen in part because she was
sounding more optimistic note and the
sense then is that the economy is going
to be in good enough shape to support
the valuations we're seeing what about
concerns about an asset bubble though we
heard her say well we're well within the
historical norm but there are people out
there that worry we could see a repeat
of what we've seen before mark well I'll
be clearly assets if you look at how
investors allocate a dollar of capital
can go to stocks bonds are cashing using
traditional asset classes are favoring
equities because there is no other game
in town at the moment and not likely to
be given what we heard of course from
Daniela in terms of the considerable
period of time being reiterated which is
measured probably in six to nine months
subsequent to the end of QE before you
even get a hint of a change in interest
rate so as a consequence equity prices I
think are destined to go higher the
question is at what level they take on
bubble-like characteristics and with the
liquidity on the sideline and the fact
that if you look inside the benchmarks
actually the average stock is not
performing as well as the headline
benchmark is there's a lot of catch-up
to be have which means money managers
are going to be desperate to put money
to work they want to get those good
names ok so what is that level where it
starts to look really frothy I mean
people have pointed to 20,000 hey we got
a long ways to go before down 20,000
yeah I think if you look out across the
spectrum I think marks right here thats
equities tend to be the only game in
town but where you're gonna find the
bubbles are in the the sort of shadow
neighborhoods right that the private
debts places the private equity places
and we've seen valuations in M&A
activity reflective of very rich
valuations maybe not bubble like
valuations but very rich valuations and
so if this trend continues I think
that's where you would start to see hope
you get what you know we're having
comments on the other day saying he
thought we were gonna see five percent
growth that might be a little optimistic
for the second quarter but if you get no
economic rebound oh it might be able to
just my sins job just to fight junk bond
yields being a record low justify the
spread between investment grade and junk
bonds being at the narrowest since 2007
you can't justify that without a central
bank being in the game I want to know
why stocks are higher today I didn't
hear anything from Janet Yellen that
should push stocks this moment I know
why she and it
now here's the point Tris just quickly
the point is is what she didn't say a
lot of people anticipated Janet yellen's
come into here and try and take some the
frolf out of this market she's back down
she didn't do it and that's one of the
big reasons why we are high today and
you'll just and lover the other thing
though I think is the fact that she was
also very committed to not being overly
dogmatic with regard to fed policy which
is to say she said will basically
accelerate or decelerate our activity
whether it be on QE or the function of
the glide path of the Fed Funds rate
predicated upon the speed of economic
activity and I think the market welcome
that that they took of you that they
weren't gonna be hardliners in terms of
QE ends we immediately start raising
interest rates and we're on our way to
normal especially what she had to say on
the economy rebounding right here take a
quick listen the committee this believes
that economic activity is rebounding in
the current quarter and will continue to
expand at a moderate pace thereafter
okay so your reaction well look it's
going to expand in the moderate pace
because there's all sorts of headwinds
there's very high levels of public debt
still going on there's low household
formations due to student loan debts
accumulations there's large structural
problem sitting in the US economy that
will impede it from hitting this five
percent growth or even a
three-and-a-half percent growth which
would be absolutely stellar given the
kinds of challenges that this economy
has so challenging also being the labor
situation I mean when are we going to
start seeing some kind of wage inflation
when are we going to start seeing that
participation rate shrink I mean or
rather grow I should say because right
now we have so many people that have
just said enough and they're not in the
labor force to begin where can I say
just a quick thing on the labor force
participation rate she said the most
clarifying statement today look part of
its demographic let's get over that
there used to be a time in the late 70s
and early 80s when the labor force
participation rate going up was actually
the bad thing because it meant two
people had to work to support a
household and now we're worried about it
coming back down these things are
structural part of it is cyclical and
it's going to take time to work itself
at back into an equilibrium if they are
structural gentlemen sorry Judy what can
the Fed really do about it
be nothing so but she's been saying for
a while that it's cyclical do they have
to back down from that now well I think
they have to be open-minded with regard
to their commitment to whether a
structural or cyclical I mean the
Philadelphia Fed for instance under
Charles plosser did a study that showed
that basically two-thirds of the decline
in the participation rate was due to
baby boomers retiring and people
becoming disabled and so really only
about a third of that is attributed to
discourage workers leaving the workforce
so maybe the participation rate isn't
necessarily the metric that is as
important in being able to identify our
measure the amount of slack that gel in
your janet yellen keys focusing on as to
why the fed is likely to be lower for
longer